anyone who's ever played Monopoly knows
how the typical game goes first a
scramble for property
it's a giant game of Hungry Hungry
Hippos roll by repeat next there's a
lull no monopolies no trading nothing to
do eventually someone gets a monopoly
and if they have half a brain they build
houses collect rent and build more
houses in a good game there's some
competition but even if more than one
player has a monopoly it's still just a
waiting game of whose property will be
landed on first and if there's only one
Monopoly it's much worse either way a
slow painful death begins for all but
one player the rest of the game can take
an hour or six but it's just monopoly
theater continuing to play even though
the winner is obvious now compare that
with a simplest game there is
uno play a matching card and pick up
more if you can't the goal is simple get
rid of your cards as you get closer to
winning you have fewer cards in your
hand making matches less likely this
naturally balances the game even with
luck involved if this is monopoly stale
and boring
this is uno up and down always uncertain
make a list of monopolies flaws and
you'll realize just how bad it is it's
mostly luck based there's lots of
waiting on other players there's a big
lull before monopolies little trading
ever happens balance is rare and the
outcome is clear early on so if you
dislike monopoly I can't blame you but I
think the amount of hate it gets is
unfair but hold that for a second let's
talk about papers please this is a game
where you work as a passport inspector
for a dystopian government you deny
entrance to helpless immigrants to
separate families and lie all to feed
your family now I love this game but
it's not fun most of your time is spent
looking at boring documents make a tiny
mistake and you get a citation which
means no food for your family even its
biggest fans find it nerve-wracking and
stressful but we love it because we know
that every annoyance was designed to
teach us something it's an experience
now monopoly is much more like papers
please it's not fun but it is good
everything you dislike was designed to
make you feel capitalism the
ridiculously unfair power of a monopoly
is purposeful and the emphasis on luck
is no mistake if it were fun it wouldn't
really be meaningful hating monopoly is
like hating 12 years of slave because it
wasn't enjoyable to watch that's not
really fair you're using the wrong
criteria so if papers please and
monopoly are so similar
why is one hated and the other loved
high-volume marketing monopoly is
advertised as family fun setting the
wrong expectations papers please knows
what it is art when you get frustrated
playing Monopoly you're looking at the
box thinking you lied
this isn't fun monopoly lets you
experience its message firsthand which
is pretty neat but it should be
advertised as such not as a family game
like uno a university professor actually
tried to correct for some of these flaws
with what he called anti-monopoly his
own take on the game and when parker
brothers sued him for copyright
infringement they further proved the
critique on capitalism of their own game